bien Jorge usted conoce muy bien la
situación de este país Cómo fue el
proceso de detención del religioso
Rolando Álvarez Bueno este Obispo fue
detenido en agosto del 2022 luego de
muchísimos días de asedio hacia su
iglesia presuntamente por algunos
mensajes hacia la crisis social y
política que vive Nicaragua que el
obispo realizado a través de las
homilías indirectamente este Obispo se
encontraba en la cárcel la modelo desde
el 9 de febrero de este año la modelo es
una cárcel de máxima seguridad en
Managua luego de haber sido condenado 26
años de prisión bajo cargos como
conspirar contra la patria y también
propagar noticia falsas en febrero de
este año El Obispo básicamente se negó a
abordar el avión junto con 222 presos
políticos que fueron desterrados y
también despojados de su nacionalidad al
obispo le despojaron la nacionalidad
Pero él se negó a irse en este avión y
debido a esto una respuesta bastante
fuerte de parte de Daniel Ortega al día
siguiente en Cadena Nacional Ortega
insultó al obispo le dijo desobediente
entre otras cosas por no acatar esta
orden del estado de no salir del país
luego de Esto fue enviado a esa cárcel
de máxima seguridad que es conocida como
el Infiernillo que mide Dos metros y
medio de largo por dos metros de ancho
según los testimonios de otros presos
que han pasado por esta prisión y bueno
tras la detención del obispo ha habido
también cierta represión hacia la
Iglesia Católica se han cancelado
actividades religiosas como las de
semana santa se han congelado las
cuentas bancarias y se han expulsado
Aproximadamente a 84 religiosos entre
sacerdotes y monjas Jorge además el
gobierno Daniel Ortega presentó al
parlamento un proyecto para reformar la
Constitución que podría acercar aún más
la oposición de qué se trata Bueno
hablamos el artículo 97 de la
Constitución Política de Nicaragua y
también de la Ley Orgánica de la Policía
Nacional lo que se sabe hasta ahora de
este borrador que envió Ortega hacia la
asamblea nacional de Nicaragua es que el
artículo
de reformar esta mención que hace que la
Policía Nacional es profesional es a
política esa partidista obediente y no
deliberante según algunos expertos en
temas de seguridad
lo que Ortega Busca legalmente
subordinar a la policía y sancionar
también a los desertores de la policía
con hasta tres años de prisión la
reforma quita esta naturaleza civil que
tenía la Policía Nacional Y la deja
solamente como un cuerpo armado
subordinado directamente a Ortega esto
se da y el contexto de que en los
últimos meses varios rangos medios y
bajos de la policía han desertado y han
huido hacia Estados Unidos